à propos de l'immigration clandestine un
département français est plus concerné
que tout autre on en parle rarement il
s'agit de l'île de mayotte à 300 km de
madagascar et à 70 kilomètres des
premières îles des comores il compte
deux cent mille habitants
les candidats au séjour affluent de
toute l'afrique on estime que 30 à 50%
de la population est constituée de
clandestins c'est le dossier de cette
édition il est signé de nos envoyés
spéciaux renaud bernard didier d'art
jour de marché à mayotte
et tout d'un coup une voiture banalisée
de la police aux frontières ariel les
vendeurs à la sauvette des clandestins
sont pris au piège
sur mamoudzou on va dire il 30 à 50 % de
la population qui est dans les styles
donc on a de fait énormément de gens de
façon régulière depuis mayotte la
française les comores sont visibles à
l'oeil nu entre les deux territoires
huit heures de mer sur des embarcations
de fortune qu'on appelle des kwassas sur
cette barque les clandestins se sont
entassés à 36 ils ont été interceptés
durant la traversée par une vedette de
la gendarmerie des malheureux attirés
par la perspective d'un niveau de vie 10
fois plus élevé que chez eux de nous
sommes des
mais les outils qui vous voulez aussi à
une bonne fille reste à la misère qui
pousse les africains vers ce petit bout
de france pour treize mille clandestins
interpellés chaque année 40 mille passe
au travers des mailles du filet depuis
la côte d'ivoire moussa a traversé toute
l'afrique 6000 km
le voici le passage vers mayotte est
moins dangereux et moins coûteux que
s'il était parti aux canaries ou en
italie
la travée c'est encore plus dangereux
le devenir à mayotte et c'est comme cela
qu'est apparue la cité africaine de
mayotte un bidonville toléré par les
autorités
les communautés s'y regroupent par pays
d'origine et les clandestins et découvre
la face cachée de l'eldorado rézé vous
retrouver mp quelque chose pour pouvoir
manger pour payer notre loyer c'est
difficile ça coûte combien le loyer y650
héros part dans ce champs de salades ou
la police et l'inspection du travail
vient d'intervenir
les ouvriers étaient payés 2 euros de
l'heure au noir par cet homme qui sourit
un patron manifestement sans état d'âme
travail d'accord vous travaillez en
famille aux côtés de la famille il ya
d'autres gens qui travaillent on en a vu
une vingtaine s'envoler il y en a deux
ou trois qui sont là ça fait quand même
une belle petite entreprise familiale
quand je vois des gens qui travaillent
70 heures par semaine payés 200 euros
par mois
il s'agit effectivement d'un esclavage
moderne non c'est pas dit pourquoi nous
il travaille pas ici ils viennent
chercher leurs marchandises
mais la police les a trouvés au chant en
train de cultiver
les clients cultive les champs non
oussaïd pourtant même quand arrive le
jour de l'expulsion
les clandestins annoncent qu'ils feront
tout pour revenir à mayotte ouattara ne
les ongles rouges avaient bien joué même
s'il a le côté reviendra demain matin
chacun et mayotte porte d'entrée de la
france dans l'océan indien procède avec
ce bateau à la moitié des reconduites à
la frontière de tout le territoire
national
mais qu'ils viennent des comores ou
d'afrique continentale les clandestins
sont souvent de retour à mayotte
quelques jours seulement après leur
expulsion